je m'appelle roma ses 23 ans et j'habite
à théoule sur mer toute l'info j'ai
réussi à réunir ma famille c'était lors
de ma première scène depuis je suis tout
petit je les ai jamais vus ensemble à
trois ans et sont séparés c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle je
pense aujourd'hui je continue à chanter
parce que à chaque fois que je chante
ils sont là quoi donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose de grand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la famille on se retourne voilà alors on
a on a on a un autre portrait c'est
antoine est une fois de plus 1 revient
sur un parcours chaotique difficile une
enfance un peu en dents de scie regarder
salut moi c'est antoine délit j'ai 22
ans quand j'étais plus jeune j'étais un
enfant c'est sage studieux
on disait c'est l'intello qui au premier
rang dans la classe voilà on critiquait
souvent ça parfois ça pouvait m'arriver
peut-être un peu rejetés par rapport à
ça maintenant j'ai vraiment trouvé ma
voie je sais ce que je veux faire je
sais que je veux chanter je ne me vois
pas faire autre chose que chanter
[Musique]
c'est fait
mais c'est quand même
c'est bon
[Musique]
les
on l'a vu antoine et bien voir du très
loin et on n'en parle pas prêt et on a
un damné pour toi là c'est pareil c'est
un portrait la moindre ça va être la
candidate et non voyante mais on aurait
été plus surpris si on avait su après
c'est vrai moi c'est maria je suis
irlandaise j'habite en or elle avait pu
me marier mais s'attend ce sens je sais
que ça se voit pas mais je suis aussi
aveugle
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imc comme ce qui a fait beaucoup parler
sur les réseaux c'est l'ouverture c'est
la tradition les juristes chante en duo
démission et vous allez assez vocalement
c'est mais ils sont pas tous au même
niveau visiblement
[Musique]
ils n'ont pas choisi la chanson
[Applaudissements]
enfin jean t1 mais ce moment seger power
sont là on voit deux femmes qui
s'affirme qui s'imposent moi j'adore ça
c'est excitant à fond ce troll ces
matches sont là les deux ils sont à côté
ça va regarder tout ça dans la doc ont
les dents planté dans la table et qui
veulent vraiment s'imposer et le deux
autres magnet gun amel ben oui c'est
maintenant la seule chose on adore
toutes les voies avec des personnalités
des grandeurs malheureusement et
pourtant mais je les aime beaucoup mais
y en ad je les aime les deux mais je
pense que pendant cette émission il y en
a deux qui vont nous énerver au fil des
mails bentelha à bien et malheureusement
elles ont un talent dingue mais pour
jouer ce sont des amis oui alors rien
alors moi amel bent j'ai trouvé qu'elle
dynamiter le programme franchement elle
est nécessaire c'est super à la porte du
peps en revanche la fa bien que j'adore
en tant que chanteuse à un artiste
formidable mais elle m'a saoulé elle m'a
rappelé alain d'altaï à la star ac qui
te fait chier
[Rires]
sur la grille je regardais de vente
avait de flash j'avais des flashs
d'armand data qui disait tuteur tient un
peu fausse côté j'avais fait c'est le
cas les leçons de chant alors c'était
pas le propos dans le débrief après la
prestation des candidates du buzz ou
sinon il est intéressant ce n'était pas
gagné d'avancé on a eu des jurys un peu
charismatique avec florent pagny et
d'autre je trouve que les leçons la tra
complémentaires auraient marc lavoine
est intéressant lara fabian qui peut
être agaçante choc a été hyper pro et
les gens ce qu'ils ont aussi envie c'est
de comprendre pourquoi il ya ce choix
les chauves que lara fabian était très
professionnelle intéressante et très
pédagogue
donc il faut arrêter de défoncer le
programme 5 millions de ça un score
énorme pour du divertissement à samedi
soir oui d'accord mais bien qu'il ya de
moins en moins et au préfet a pris au
prix où j'ai acheté cette année oui mais
vous savez bien qu'il ya de moins en
moins de spectateurs devant les chaînes
traditionnelles puisqu'il ya maintenant
la tnt ce qui sera intéressant par
contre c'est de regarder par rapport à
ce que vous avez dit la courbe
d'audience c'est un jour on pourrait
regarder la courbe des autres et parce
que le désir sont à voir il parle pas de
ça je vous parle de l'histoire qui est
racontée avant la chance d'accord très
clair que droits intérêts oui pour être
mené par exemple vous avez cette femme
aveugle
si vous racontez pas l'histoire avant
qui est plutôt attachante avec toute sa
famille est ce que vous avez envie de la
regarder chanter mais oui chanteur est
ce que lorsque vous regardez le
programme fois de temps en temps et est
ce que vous trouvez ça de bon niveau et
de mai déjà
que laurent fabien at-il autant de
malveillance faut connaître déjà donné
merci déjà la carrière qu'elle as déjà
c'est exceptionnel elle a une technique
vocale et après ce que c'est pas la
production qui lui demande de jouer un
rôle pour est ce que c'est vraiment elle
parce que là elle attire les fours sur
sa propre personne
est-ce que c'est pas la production qui
doit jouer un rôle au site mais traîne
toujours en coulisses c'est bernard
montiel oui alors est ce que je dois
dire on a vu les larmes une fois de plus
de l'heure à fabian savez que c'est une
femme hyper sensible qui a le coeur là
au bord des larmes tout le temps il est
vrai que cette jeune femme qui a chanté
qui était mal voyantes salle a rappelé
sa maman elle l'a dit et là je comprends
l'émotion passée moi j'ai connu sa maman
féroce le portrait craché donc imaginé
une dame comme ça c'est normal qu'elle
ai pleuré moi j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour l'heure à fabian et je veux dire
que j'ai regardé l'émission avait
beaucoup de bonheur et j'ai adoré les
altercations justement trouvé amel bent
et obispo qui se sent délaissée par sa
très controversée soutien doré est ce
qu'il est mais bon abbas car bellevue
pour un contrôle pas du tout ce qu'elle
veut être une femme libre et alors la
balade et tout le monde bravo mlb
corps et âme pour vous c'est à débuts
convaincants oui ou non j'ai pas compris
votre question c'est un défi sur un
court où tu n'as pas compris mais les
maquereaux et sérieux oui mais toi grave
ici ou là mise en prison
bonne surprise oui oui oui non non bien
sûr évidemment
alors je dis merci beaucoup